corsica sits here a short distance from
the italian coast throughout the
medieval and early modern periods its
people spoke corsican and italian it was
economically culturally and politically
tied to the italian peninsula for most
of its existence and yet today it's a
part of france which raises the question
why why is corsica french and not
italian so throughout the medieval
period corsica swapped hands a few times
from pisa to genoa to aragon to france
to milan to a bank briefly to france
again and finally back to genoa and
across these years the people of corsica
had revolted numerous times and retaking
the islands often proved costly for its
overlords and in that same spirit came
the year 1729 when a heavy tax burden
led the people of corsica to revolt
against their genoese rulers it briefly
became a kingdom before declaring the
creation of a republic previously
revolts in corsica were nasty but
ultimately doomed affairs however this
time the revolt lasted for decades
because now the corsicans were being
supported by others and by others i mean
the british this wasn't out of some
kind-hearted wish to see the corsicans
prosper that would be silly in fact the
actual reason was to deprive the french
of the islands as the genoese were
paying french troops to suppress the
rebellion as the rebellion went on the
genoese knew that they'd lost the island
and so opted to sell it to france france
agreed to the sale and soon after sent a
lot of troops to corsica and the
rebellion was crushed in 1769 so that's
france's control over corsica
established and settled then right well
no when the french revolutionary wars
broke out corsica rebelled again and
soon threw in the lot with the british
as a sort of shared kind of sovereign
british colony the french retook the
island after a couple of years and they
were in possession of it when napoleon
was defeated and exiled he briefly came
back was defeated again and as a part of
the congress of vienna europe's major
powers decided to take france's recent
gains from her yet corsica remained a
part of france and this was mostly due
to france buying it prior to the french
revolution since the goal of the
congress was to mostly reset europe to
before the french revolution not to
simply humiliate france which upset the
corsican since all that british support
didn't go very far as such corsica would
remain a part of france for the
foreseeable future but its inclusion
wasn't guaranteed you see up until the
mid 19th century italian was the most
spoken language on the island and so to
many in what would soon become italy
corsica was one of their own one man
with such an opinion was giuseppe
garibaldi who after the conquest of rome
by italy in 1870 called for the
immediate invasion of corsica to which
the italian king said no because he
didn't feel like picking a fight with
france when world war 1 kicked off there
were some discussions by the central
powers that if italy were to join their
side corsica as well as some other
territories would be handed to them if
they won of course italy sided with the
anton but the idea of corsica rightfully
belonging to italy would persist until
benito mussolini came to power as you
know italy joined world war ii by
invading france and after its full italy
didn't get corsica it remained a part of
vichy france until 1942 when germany
decided that it didn't need to exist
anymore and so along with italy they put
an end to it with this italy came into
control of corsica which mussolini had
wanted and this control lasted a whole
year since italy was defeated in 1943.
soon afterwards the brand new italy had
joined the allies and from it french
troops liberated the island and
thereafter corsica would remain a part
of france i hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
a special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly money maker corso wolfe
jordan longley adam stalter jerry lambda
marcus arsenault y and hockey words
about books podcast rodney martin
captain cydog marvin cassel casaugustav
swan spencer lightfoot boogerly wuggly
common yoon winston k wood aaron the
white matthew shipley alex schwinn
maxson flaudio maggie patzkowski anthony
beckett the mcquapper corey turner
coppertone spinning through plates
charles the first ben evanson and
scottish trekkie